♪~~~~
はじめ：お前ーお前紙コップでピラミッド作ったことあるか？
たなっち：ないない
はじめ：うそでしょ
たなっち：紙コップは飲み物を飲むものなので
たなっち：僕はそういうので遊ばないので
はじめ：作った人みたことはある？
たなっち：あーありますそれは、もう全然ある
はじめ：もはや、紙コップはピラミッドを作るもの？
はじめ：ヒトは紙コップを見るとついつ重ねて重ねてピラミッドを作りたくなる
はじめ：私もかつて紙コップを大量に買い巨大なピラミッドを作ったとき~
アッまずい
はじめ：ものすごい満足感に襲われ
はじめ：それぐらい、それぐらい
はじめ：やっぱものを積み重ねて高いものを作る
はじめ：いいんじゃないですか
はじめ：で、それを紙コップでやるならまだ分かるんですけどもー
はじめ：巨大バケツでピラミッドを作ったら
はじめ：たかが紙コップで重ねて3日間寝れなくなったから
はじめ：巨大バケツで巨大なピラミッドを作ってしまうと
はじめ：1ヶ月はなれなくなると思うんですよ
はじめ：これをもし、これを使って
はじめ：今怒った？
たなっち：今怒った
たなっち：どんって
はじめ：どんっつったよね
はじめ：巨大な紙コップじゃないｗ
はじめ：巨大んバケツでピラミッドを作ったら
はじめ：それをみてみたいしすごい満足感が得られるんじゃないかなぁと思って
はじめ：今日は業者に頼んだ最大の大きさのバケツ
はじめ：巨大バケツで巨大なピラミッドを作ってみようと思います
はじめ：では早速やっていきましょう
はじめ：では早速作っていきましょう
はじめ：数えたところ巨大バケツが21個あったんで
はじめ：6個5､4､3､2､1っていう感じでピラミッドを作っていきます
はじめ：よーしイクゾー
はじめ：待ってすごいかりく、火力だなぁ
はじめ:ではまず1段目作っていきます
はじめ：これさーまじで重いんだよね
はじめ：重いよねこれ
たなっち：重い重い
はじめ：一段目できました
はじめ：どうだ
はじめ：二段目行きます
はじめ：おうおうどーどーどーどー
はじめ：もう2で
たなっち；確かに待ってこれ
はじめ：あ、あっあっ
たなっち：いったいったいった
はじめ：伝わるかなぁ汗
はじめ：ギリースーツを着ると普通の人の８倍疲れるんだぁ
はじめ：はい、二段目終了しました
はじめ：なると思ってもらえると
たなっち：いやでかいな
はじめ：やばいよ結構
はじめ：ぉあー２でこれか
はじめ：じゃあ３段目行きます
はじめ：やばいもう３段目で俺を超えた
はじめ：はい、というわけで３段目まで来ました
はじめ：もう俺も身長
はじめ：もう私の身長を抜いております
はじめ：とりあえず４段目行きましょう
はじめ：待ってこれもう無理な気がしてきた
はじめ：わ～う～
はじめ：やばい高い
はじめ：やばいすごいよ高いｗ高い高い
はじめ：よし、できました
はじめ：もうやばい、もうやばいすもう届かないです僕じゃ
はじめ：うわぁもうやばいほんとに高くなっちゃった
はじめ：久しぶりに〜
はじめ：はい次で５段目です
はじめ：こっからだと、え、これ届くのかな
はじめ：投げたら意外といけそうな気もするなぁ
はじめ：あ～～～～～～～
はじめ：コントロールがあればいける気がする
はじめ：はい
はじめ：もうだめだなんか個人の力だとこれが限界だ
はじめ：ちょっと脚立持ってきてるんで脚立使います
はじめ：ぅおっし
はじめ：できましたー
はじめ：俺より全然でかいかんね今
はじめ：あと１個が非常に難しい
はじめ：もう脚立を使っても1個が届かない感じだったんで
はじめ：どうしよう
はじめ：一か八かだーやってみるっきゃねー
はじめ：ほっ
はじめ：うわ～～～～ん
はじめ：はい、というわけで
はじめ：ラスト一個です
はじめ：いきます
はじめ：しゃー完成でーす
たなっち：おおおーーーー
はじめ：やったたなっちできたぞ
たなっち；すげー
はじめ：やったーできたぞ
たなっち；すげー　フーフー
はじめ：フーフー　フーフー
はじめ：帰ろ
たなっち：はい
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】